[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute ein
richtig leckeres knoblauchbrot das ist
einfach nur lecker wir haben letztens
gemacht wollten eigentlich grillen und
haben soll ich habe es dann auf gegessen
bevor überhaupt angefangen haben zu
grillen das heißt schon was danach komme
übrigens papst sagt und mit kann das
grillen auf den nächsten tag verschoben
ich war jetzt zuallererst in pfiffigen
teig falls eben ein kanal noch nicht
abonniert haben dann tut es jetzt nach
und aktiviert die glocke damit ihr
solche genialen rezepte auch nicht
verpasst ich mache für den teig einfach
ein ganz ganz einfachen aber genialen
teig ich nehme mir mehr die ganz genaue
mengenangaben stehen unten in der
video beschreibung
groß infobox also das gleiche es gibt
jetzt mehr da rein ich benutzer
trockenhefe weil sie einer meinung wenn
das hat man eigentlich immer im schrank
ihr könnt auch frische hefe verwenden
trockenhefe gebe ich dazu wie salz und
pfeffer kommen direkt mit rein das waren
jetzt alle trockenen zutaten wenningmann
schneebesen wo früher mal ganz kurz
durch machen wir hier in der mitte so
ein bisschen platz und dann gebe ich die
flüssigen zutaten dazu hier habe ich
milch die ist lauwarm damit sich einfach
der teig besser verbindet das
funktioniert mit kalter milch nämlich
nicht so gut wie butter die habe ich in
der mikrowelle zu lassen jetzt haben wir
ein bisschen länger gebraucht mit dem
dreh zu starten deshalb ist jetzt schon
wieder ein bisschen fest geworden aber
das reicht unten alcom noch mit dazu
[Musik]
solche jetzt hier so ungefähr seit zwei
minuten und der teig der muss so weit
sein dass er gerade so nicht mehr an den
händen klebt ich habe jetzt in all der
größe l also schon sehr groß sei daher
brauche ich dazu so ein teelöffel mehr
mail bei einem all größer ist oder er
müsste die menge genau reichen haben
sagte mir einmal
meine hände sind jetzt so richtig kann
sie waschen kann dabei helfen
wenn wir das media unten herholz für
eine vor ort suchen mich beschmutzen und
meinen händen und ich könnte jetzt auch
auf der arbeitsfläche weiter habe ich
ein viel besseres gefühl hat in der
schüssel
da oben typ 405
also ein bisschen ein bisschen einfach
hier auf den teig
das ist schon so machen ja das ist das
ist ein teelöffel das ist so hätte ich
das gewusst hätte mit wem wann wie lange
braucht sogar mal
papa drauf
[Gelächter]
den teig noch so eine gute minute weiter
und dann kann er auch schon sohn also
ist wenn die kamera wieder über den
haben wir nun dieses ist ein bisschen
öde
der tag ist immer richtig schön software
fühlt sich an wie ein ohrläppchen bist
du einfach mal genau an dieser stelle
mal fühlen und schreibt auch so eins zu
eins dann schreibt man die kommentare ob
er das spürt ich werde jetzt hier
einfach so folgenden trick anwenden ich
nehme den teig und ziehe den auf einer
arbeitsfläche einfach zu mir dann habe
ich nämlich so eine schöne runde kugel
viele wege führen nach rom ihr könnt
auch anders machen aber so finde ich
eigentlich von easy und jetzt musste er
gehen und zwar 30 minuten lang und ich
mach das jetzt nicht in der schüssel
seinen namen ich nehme mir direkt mein
backblech ich habe jetzt hier diesmal
das gelochte genommen ihr könnt doch das
emaillierten ihm ich verlinke ich beide
in die infobox
nicht da also dann ist ein backpapier
natürlich oben drauf lege ich einfach
den teig so in die mitte den wänden
vergleich noch flach da muss jetzt aber
erstmal ein bisschen entspannen und
daher wird jetzt schön schlafen gelegt
eine halbe stunde an einem warmen ort
dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder wobei
in der zwischenzeit machen wir die
knoblauchbutter damit wir uns die zeit
einsparen so machen hat ich pack das
jetzt in den geschlossenen ofen weil die
küche ist offen und hefe tag mag keinen
durchzog daher doch lieber den ofen
[Musik]
für die knoblauchbutter habe ich jetzt
rote zwiebel fein gehackt außerdem noch
frische petersilie fein gehackt und ich
habe die mutter früh genug aus dem
kühlschrank genommen denn hier muss
richtig schön weich sein ich gebe jetzt
erstmal knoblauch mit dazu nicht
übertreibt gar nicht immer einfach zweit
sehen wenn euch das zu heftig ist und er
noch im bett habt
dann macht gerne eine rein haben sie
übertreiben oder russische clubs das ist
so groß da haben wir die antwort dann
müssen wir zwei nehme so und nachdem ich
das da reingepresst habe gebe ich von
aperture sie dir dazu und auch die rote
zwiebel ich brauche nicht alles von der
roten zwiebel den rest nämlich für
meinen salat aber schon bald wieder so
groß
da nehme ich jetzt nur die hälfte und
dann kommen wir noch salz und pfeffer
rein und ich habe noch ein tipp für euch
ich weiß dass hat aktuell nicht jeder
daheim weil das auch brandneu ist aber
statt all der zutaten könnt ihr zimmer
warme butter also weiche butter nur mit
einem teelöffel mit meinem café de paris
gewürzt wird es nach schmeckt so
toll schmeckt so gut und
natürlich das einmal hier in meine
handfläche zeigen ich vor links euch in
die infobox vielleicht könnt ihr euch
das fürs nächste mal zulegen und dann
spart durch die ganze schnitzel arbeit
und verrührt einfach die butter mit dem
gewürz aber für euch wollte ich jetzt
auch einfach mal eine alternative ob es
ein bisschen sich darauf hereinfallen
das war mal eine alternative zeigen so
salz und pfeffer verrühren und dann
haben wir
die gehzeit ist jetzt rum und tag ist
schön aufgegangen als ich richtig schön
entspannen wir sehen uns einfach die
finger und drücken den flach ob ihr das
sind rund oder oval das ist euch
überlassen
ich hoffe machen uns heute oval noch
wirklich also der gegner im ofen auch
nochmal auf also wirklich lang ziehen so
perfekt genau so ein zentimeter dick
ungefähr und jetzt nehmen wir uns ein
messer und schneiden ein nicht durch
leute das ist super wichtig wir
schneiden nur ein kann setzt das zu
entscheiden können ihr euch kann ich ja
nicht fragen soll ich noch mal quer
schneiden oder soll ich dir nur so
längst lassen ja so lassen oder noch mal
so schön gruselig
du hast das gesagt wir machen das jetzt
wichtig ist wie gesagt dass er das nicht
komplett durchschneidet so jetzt nehmen
wir uns die
knoblauch ich will schon was kräuter
sagen haben die sind ja auch kräuter
drin die monster knoblauchbutter und
streichen die richtig schön da drauf und
die farben sind so schön
echt ne dieses lila in verbindung mit
grün eigentlich müsste man sich die
doppelte portion machen weil man das
auch so ganz gut tippen kann ich nehme
mir jetzt käse ich nehme heute gouda
käse können ihr könnt und mozzarella
nehmen thaler was ich werde ihn jetzt
aber nochmal in so streifen schneiden
und dann gebe ich den zwischen die
rillen die wir uns vorgestellt haben
das doch ruhig schön raus tragen also
geist doch nicht mit dem käse wenn jetzt
kein käse fans etwas mir gar nicht
vorstellen kann dann lasst ihn ruhig
ganz weg und das ist einfach ein
knoblauch butterbrots auch sehr lecker
[Musik]
unser knobloch käse brot kommt jetzt in
den vorgeheizten backofen 190 grad ober
und unterhitze für 25 minuten
[Musik]
mein tipp ist es auf jeden fall noch
lauwarm ist schmeckt aber auch kalt es
schmeckt auch noch am nächsten tag man
sieht uns hat es auch gut geschmeckt
dass nur noch die hälfte übrig haben sie
was ist los mit uns wie wir haben wir
die hälfte im sap schon beim
fotografieren aufgefuttert das schmeckt
so ist hofft so lecker wer das nicht
ausprobiert ist selbst schuld ist
einfach so macht das ist anfänger
geeignet ist einfach und wenn ihr solch
genialen rezepte nicht verpassen möchte
dann seid auch beim nächsten mal gerne
dabei und ansonsten wünsche ich euch
einen wunderschönen tag bis zum nächsten
mal auf die kitchen
[Musik]